Think about your hometown.
Think about the place where important
things have happened in your life
and in the lives of those you love.
Now, what if you woke up one day
and it was just gone?
My very first film
was about a town that disappeared.
I was 16 at the time,
and my family was on a vacation
to see the great
national parks of the West.
And somewhere in Wyoming
we happened upon a classic tourist trap:
an old Western ghost town.
And admission was five dollars a head,
and there were six of us
and my dad was frugal.
So his idea was
send John in alone with the video camera,
and the rest of the family
will just watch the videotape later.
So I ventured in alone
and attempted to capture
all of the mystery and mystique
of this town lost to time.
Now, old Western ghost towns
capture our imagination
because they are a touchstone
to America's pioneer history.
But in time I would come to understand
that ghost towns still happen.
Wildfires rage, earthquakes
strike, levees break.
But more commonly,
it is the insidious, slow-motion disaster.
Layoffs at the textile mill.
The closing of a steel plant.
Or the suburban sprawl
that slowly sucks all life
out of an old downtown,
leaving it in constant decline.
The COVID-19 lockdown turned
every city into a temporary ghost town,
and we’re still not sure if some
communities can emerge
from the economic devastation.
And it also taught us that the forces
that destroy cities are big and complex
and out of our control
and sometimes impossible to predict.
But there is something that we can do,
that we can control,
that will help us navigate
these challenges.
We can develop community resilience.
We can build civic pride
and a strong identity for our communities
that will give us the determination
to survive and to succeed or to rebuild,
even when rebuilding from ruins.
And this is the power of the civic story.
I first learned that a story
can change a city
from a barber.
When I was 24, I set out
to make my first real film,
a feature documentary about Route 66,
once known as the Mother Road
and the Main Street of America.
And along this road is a tiny town
in northern Arizona called Seligman.
And in this town
is where I met the barber,
Angel Delgadillo,
and he became one
of the narrators in my film.
Now, hundreds of towns along Route 66
became 21st-century ghost towns
when they were bypassed
by the interstate freeway system.
And Angel told me about the day
that they opened
Interstate 40 across Arizona
and bypassed his town of Seligman.
Up until that day,
hundreds or even thousands of cars
would pass by his barber shop window
every day.
He told me that the minute they
open the lanes of I-40,
the traffic stopped.
And it was as if they had gone
to the edge of town
and put up a gate and forbidden
people to come into town,
like somebody had turned off a faucet.
For years after this,
he sat in his barber chair
and stared out at the empty streets
and realized Seligman was dying.
And he grew bitter, and he grew angry.
And then he realized something important.
While Seligman may be off the beaten path,
it wasn't obsolete.
It had something special.
Route 66 was an important part
of American history,
and Seligman was part of that story.
And he had a hunch that if the entire
community embraced that heritage,
it would lead to a future.
So they swept the sidewalks
and painted and cleaned up
and petitioned the state of Arizona
to mark the old road,
the route through town,
as a historic highway.
And it took ten years,
but eventually they did it.
And the state of Arizona made
the stretch from Williams
through Seligman to Kingman
an official historic Route 66 Highway,
and the iconic 66 Highway
shield signs returned.
And that's when I met him.
By then, his barbershop
had morphed into a visitor center,
and he was selling maps and souvenirs
and mugs and fridge magnets
and occasionally still giving
a shave and a haircut.
But mostly he was telling the story
of Route 66 and posing for photos.
And this story, their story,
eventually revived Seligman.
And not just Seligman,
but dozens of towns, from Chicago to LA,
were inspired by Angel and Seligman,
and they also embraced their heritage
and found a way forward.
On a recent trip there,
the Seligman visitor center told me
they were averaging
160,000-200,000 visitors per year
and Angel is still posing
for photos 24 hours a day,
as a life-sized cutout in his barber shop.
As a filmmaker focused on telling
the stories of cities and towns,
I've observed something firsthand.
Communities that are successful,
that are managing to stage a comeback
or revitalize after an era of demise
are places where people of the towns
seem to know their story.
They know where they've been
and where they're going.
Now why is this?
Why does story matter?
Well, here's a clue.
It comes from a groundbreaking
psychological study
done by Emory University
and the Emory Center for the Study of Myth
and Ritual in American Life.
And in this study, they determined
that the single biggest predictor
of a child's emotional strength
and health and resilience was story.
The more a child knew
about their family history,
the stronger they were.
Somehow, the stories
of their ancestors and relatives,
how they overcame obstacles
and endured hardship,
seem to infuse children
with confidence and courage and grit.
Well, as it turns out,
what's true for a child
is true for a community.
Tenino, Washington is a small town
about 15 miles from my hometown
of Olympia, Washington.
It’s [has] a population
of about 2,000 people.
It was founded as a sandstone city.
Sandstone from the quarries in Tenino
were used to build some
of the West Coast’s grandest buildings:
churches and libraries
and railroad stations.
And if you walk
Tenino's Main Street today,
you'll see many buildings
built from this sandstone.
As a matter of fact, the city
council recently passed a law
requiring that any new building
in Tenino in the central district
must use a certain percentage
of sandstone in its construction.
And this gives the town a unique look
and a physical and visual connection
to their own story.
I recently traveled to Tenino to create
a short film about this community
and their connection to their story.
Tenino's toughest time
was the Great Depression.
The only bank in town closed,
and they ran out of money.
There was a run on physical currency,
and the city leaders at the time decided,
well, why don't we just print our own?
And they devised a way
to print wooden dollars,
and they distributed this
throughout the community
to allow commerce to continue.
Fast forward, the year 2020,
the COVID pandemic hits,
another economic crisis.
Well, everybody in Tenino
remembered the Great Depression
and the wooden dollars,
and they thought,
why don't we just do it again?
The 1870s-era printing press
that had printed money back then
was still down at the local
history museum.
So they poured the ink and fired it up
and started printing 25-dollar
COVID relief funds.
And they distributed this to residents.
Now, Walmart and Amazon
do not accept this.
But that’s OK.
In fact, that's the point.
Tenino businesses do.
And so in addition to being
a relief program,
it is an economic stimulus
for the local economy,
encouraging people to spend
their money at local shops,
businesses and restaurants,
the ones owned by their family,
friends and neighbors.
Now, I noticed there was a strange
Latin phrase on this money,
and I asked the mayor what it meant.
And he said, “Loosely translated,
it means 'We got this.'"
And I thought, there is another
example of a community
that summoned confidence
in the face of a crisis
empowered by their civic story.
Now, sometimes we get stuck in a cynical
and self-defeating narrative.
Welcome to Buffalo, New York.
In all fairness,
Buffalo has had a bit
of a streak of bad luck.
Shortly after being founded,
we were burned to the ground
by the British.
The Erie Canal made us one of the richest,
most important cities in America.
But when shipping was replaced
by trains and trucking,
we went from indispensable to obsolete.
And in the 1950s, a mass exodus began,
and we've lost roughly
half our population.
The great blizzard of '77
made us a constant punchline
and punching bag of national comedians.
The Christmastime closing
of Bethlehem Steel in 1983
and then four straight
Super Bowl losses in the 1990s.
I won’t go into the details,
just Google: “wide right.”
By the time I arrived in Buffalo in 2005,
you really can't blame people here
for feeling like,
"You know, we're just never going to win."
Matter of fact, I remember
my first trip to Coles,
a beloved neighborhood bar.
I told some of the local folks
that I had just moved here
from the Seattle area.
And instead of saying,
“Welcome to our city,”
they said, "What happened?
Did you lose a bet?"
This was Buffalo then,
a city walking through life
with a "kick me" sign on its back.
And since making Buffalo home,
I have made several short films
that, along with other artists and authors
and photographers and bloggers,
have helped to change the conversation.
In particular,
the film "Buffalo: America's
Best Designed City,"
helped to reframe things.
The film tells the story
of why Frederick Law Olmsted,
once called Buffalo
"the best planned city in America,
if not the world."
And then it tells how he went on
to design and build the first
and best park system
in America right here.
It then honestly recounts
how we squandered that legacy
by making a series of mistakes
that did severe damage to the city
and to our neighborhoods.
But in the final act,
it tells the story of how today's
generation is rediscovering
and embracing Buffalo's exquisite urban
design and the historic neighborhoods,
and are committing themselves
to the long and difficult task
of fixing and restoring it.
If the old story in Buffalo
was “we’re unlucky,”
the new story is
"we'll make our own luck."
If the old story was "we're doomed,"
the new story is "we're destined."
I think one of my favorite
things about Buffalo
is that it is a city
with a true narrative arc.
I mean, we've got highs and lows
and wins and losses
and setbacks and comebacks.
And I think it is this narrative arc
and our deep connection to it
that is our city's secret weapon
and strange appeal.
I mean, to be in Buffalo
is to live in a city that has embarked
on the hero's journey.
What about your town?
Has it set foot on that journey?
I hate to say it,
but I think one of the biggest threats
to our cities is our own apathy.
In too many places we have given up
or given in or grown to accept
things the way they are.
A well-told civic story
can be the spark that rekindles
love for our place.
It can be the spark
that rekindles our pride.
The civic story, as we have learned,
is not just about history.
It's also about the future,
about what our cities are becoming.
And that's the story that we live
and participate in every day.
I’m a filmmaker, and I love
to tell the civic story of a place
through the medium which I consider
the modern-day campfire,
that flickering light in the dark
that can gather a hushed crowd
to experience something together.
But there are many ways
to tell the civic story,
no matter your skill set.
Do you like to talk to people?
Start a podcast series.
Do you write or take photos?
Create a book or a calendar
that chronicles the life
and times of your town.
Fight to preserve an important building.
Make a musical album or a mural.
You could collect city memorabilia
and use it to decorate your walls
and your shelves and your bicycles
and bumpers and computers and phone cases.
All of these are ways to learn
and share the civic story.
So think about your place.
Where are you from?
Does it have a past worth remembering?
Does it have a future worth hoping for?
If so, a story can change a city.
Thank you.
(Applause)